i'm told snake from moscow has fixed
their mic let's try it once more snake
please are you with us from moscow
hi can you hear me now yes snake welcome
hi thank you for uh taking my call uh i
guess my question would be a lot more
theoretical rather than pertaining to
particular issues but there is a debate
among liberal russian elites or general
anti-war population on the purpose and
value of non-violent protests when
russia has engaged in an attempt to
destroy ukrainian statehood and the
anti-war protests which are peaceful
usually manifest themselves as
graffiti is writing on cash etc trying
to distribute anti-war messaging without
getting into any type of violent or
physical altercation with anybody or
anything
so my question you know is do you think
there is any value or purpose in
non-violent measures in a time which is
essentially war enacted by our
government against other people this is
a really great question because at some
point you know all of us who as a
principal are against violence
sometimes we get to a point where we say
well we're trying to protest horribly
violent acts like the invasion of
ukraine
with signs and writing on dollar bills
and it just doesn't if i'm hearing you
correctly snake you're saying it does is
it really going to achieve anything is
it is it is it enough
that is the sense that's this is nothing
in comparison to state propaganda and
therefore is useless and doesn't need to
exist yeah i mean i i am i am
sympathetic to that question
and where i come down is and and maybe
i'm naive or idealistic
i just don't know that the random people
on the street getting violent is
actually going to have the effect on the
policy
that maybe we would like it to compared
to
crippling sanctions
uh um
governments saying
we are not going to allow this or or
what it's it's just hard for me to
imagine it's you know to some degree
snake
it's like when these people say if the
jews had handguns world war ii wouldn't
have happened and every historian that
has looked at it says that's just not
true so i understand the instinct but i
wonder
how fac how based in reality the idea is
i just don't know
thank you and if i can my second
question is going to be slightly more
more practical
how do you think we can build bridges
between populations that are not
existing in the same reality in the
united states it seems to me like
anybody moderate versus trumpet slash
mega hat people
in russia it's the so-called white nicks
who are soviet-era
ideologues versus more
younger liberal or just plain more
moderate population of russia do you
think it is even possible to build
bridges between such groups of people
who don't seem to align anywhere
so i think it's possible
here's the answer at the at the
individual level every expert i've
spoken to says the way you build those
bridges is you have to just start with
what we agree on and sometimes it's very
little but there's usually some
agreement uh do we agree that we prefer
solutions without violence yes okay
let's use that and then see where we get
to a point of disagreement this is a
long arduous time consuming process
at the mass scale level how do we
deprogram people who won't even accept
basic facts i don't have the answer to
that unfortunately
okay thank you very much for taking my
question so before you go
you're calling from russia
yeah from moscow and so what is the j
would you say the general sentiment
there is that people like the invasion
of ukraine or people are against the
invasion of ukraine
uh i have to say that i will have a
certain moscow liberal bias because
that's the area where i was raised and
my family has always been uh critical of
the government there is not a single
person in my immediate circles that are
fans of this government okay but i would
say that just from my own personal
experience just looking at cars or
driving or parking anywhere i don't see
a single z
sign there is no single i would say
personal initiative to install anything
that is commemorative to this war
all i've seen is state council local
efforts which are sponsored from the
state from the federal budget to try and
convince people to engage in such
practices and some type of coercion
that's happening for example in
kindergartens oftentimes parents
discover that the school trip or the
kindergarten trip they send their
children to was actually a sort of
patriotic
event
because they then later find pictures of
the children posed in the letter z on
social media or that's the patriotic
education trump keeps talking about now
listen do you feel safe expressing your
views antagonistic to the government
on here yes
over at my university i've already sort
of spoken myself into 15 years of prison
if anybody would like
deep
dig anywhere around me uh so um this is
just a weird stasis that i know that if
anybody looked at me or what i've been
writing what i've been saying it is
quite possible that i will face some
sort of fine or maybe even jail time
after all a person was arrested
yesterday for working out with a
printout of russian constitution onto
the streets
[Music]
and there are uh unfortunately i'm also
you know like a liberal i'm a college
professor so if any of my students
decide that they don't like me they can
write a letter to celeste committee
which is like a prosecutor's office of
russia and i will be gone
so
but on the other hand unfortunately my
family has had this same experience
since 1930s so it's not like we're
inexperienced in this particular
situation sure so it's sure
it's just weird and uh i don't like it
well stay safe snake and um how how
upset were you by the closure of
mcdonald's in russia
actually there is uh a lot of working
mcdonald's spots like i
yeah i visited kazan which is a city in
tatarstan a republic within russia and
they have plenty working mcdonald's i
think all of the mcdonald's is located
at airports are working as well i think
franchisees are still open while those
that were commanded by u.s headquarters
so they have all closed i see i see all
right well snake thank you for the call
and stay safe there
thank you all right there is snake from
moscow and that will do it for today
we'll take a quick break we will take
calls again